well good evening we were saying earlier
that the last time I was here doing an
event like this with with Thomas Piketty
and I suspected that slightly more
people had got to the end of Michael
Lewis's books than Thomas Piketty 'z but
as Hanna was saying Michael has written
a lot of books sold more than nine
million copies yes I think there's still
quite a lot of journalists and writers
who don't resent his success maybe just
a few left economic journalists and
financial journalists I think have a
particular reason to harbor resentment
of you because you've taken you've
trodden all over our territory and
actually made it interesting and
exciting and entertaining starting with
liars poker but also slices of the
financial crisis with boomerang and the
big short and when I heard that you'd
written flash boys about high-frequency
trading I actually thought for a minute
whether it might be a dare that someone
had said I bet you can't do this I bet
you can't make algorithmic trading
interesting with the most the sort of
exciting action at the beginning
involves labor laying fiber optic cable
but it's still a really good read so
annoying
but we're here at least partly to talk
about your latest book I should say also
of course you still do all this great
journalism as well for Vanity Fair
interviewing Barack Obama and writing
for The New Yorker and many others and
Bloomberg for whom I now work as well
but we are here to talk about the latest
book the undoing project which is about
the friendship of two behavioral
psychologists one of whom who went on to
win the Nobel Prize and I guess you know
the obvious question is you know how did
you find these two people you are famous
for bringing to life very complex
often sort of shady difficult to
understand areas by finding the right
people to follow how did you how did you
alight on these two characters tell us a
bit about them well I'll tell you how it
came about because it is the oddest
experience I've had writing books
typically with books for me I find a
subject decide in a few months that it's
a book spend a year and a half figuring
out what the book is and six months
writing it and I'm done this thing goes
back more than a decade when I first
started thinking about it and the way it
began so more than a decade ago I wrote
a book called Moneyball which God knows
probably know his audience knows about
because they didn't didn't know what
didn't find it it was a you know it was
a book about American baseball so it
didn't travel very well but it was well
so I have to quickly explain this book
because that's the origin of the undoing
project the story in Moneyball was about
a team that had no money having to
compete against teams with lots of money
in professional baseball I mean I think
the structure and put in British
football far the same right they're poor
teams and rich teams and I had this poor
team in my backyard that was at 1/5 the
sums of the rich teams and was running
circles around all these rich teams and
it made no sense to me
because I thought if the market for the
baseball players were efficient the rich
teams would just buy all the good
players and the poor teams wouldn't
stand a chance so this story that
emerges it turns out the market for
baseball players is not efficient it
turns out that the the people who were
the baseball experts of the Scouts who
were evaluating baseball players
misjudge the players and the team that I
wrote about the Oakland A's explained to
me how this all worked and I thought
when I was writing that story you know
someone once said an explanation is
where the mind comes to rest and my man
mine came to rest like a step short of
where it should have when I wrote that
book because where came to rest was
isn't it amazing that these people can
be so miss valued that that this team is
is able to find kind of undervalued
players and the moment I thought ah this
is the story I was I was in the locker
room of the Oakland A's interviewing
players about what it felt like to be on
this oddly managed team and for the
first time kind of saw them it was after
a game so I'm coming out of the showers
the first time I saw them naked and it
was such an unpleasant sight they they
were they kind of got a cankles and fat
rolls and the baseball uniform covers up
all sorts of stuff and they just didn't
look like professional athletes and I
went to the management and said you know
if you if you line your the bodies of
your players against a wall and asked
anybody what they did for a living
nobody would guess they were
professional athletes they would guess
they were you know accountants and and
they said that's that's part of the
point they said that that one of the
things we look for are players who are
physically defective in some way because
by using statistical analysis to get to
their performance value we can find we
can we know how good they are but the
market is deceived by what they look
like so as a result they had a player
with two club feet they had players they
had players it was you know it was a bit
of an island of misfit toys situation
and so I thought wow you know forget
they're athletes
think of them as corporate employees
they're doing what they do in front of
them for you for a living and front of
millions of people there's statistics
attached to every move they make on a
while they're on the job they've been
doing the same job for a hundred years
if these people can be Mis valued who
can't be Mis value so that was my story
so that book comes out and it's reviewed
by a writing team of Cass Sunstein who's
a legal scholar and worked in the Obama
administration is now teaching at
Harvard and Richard Thaler who just won
the Nobel Prize in Economics
and it's kind of one of the founding
fathers maybe the founding father
behavioral economics and they say very
gently but nevertheless damningly mr.
Lewis does not understand the point of
his own book and it is oh it isn't it's
really an interesting story that he's
got that this team has figured out that
if you use statistical adjustment
instead of intuitive judgment to work
out who a good baseball player is you're
gonna you're gonna do a better job of it
but the he'd never asked they say about
me truthfully that why this is happening
like why why is it that experts in the
market for baseball flash misjudge the
assets and they said and this question
has been answered by these two Israeli
psychologists Danny Kahneman and Amos
Tversky whose work would a series of
papers really it's kind of like a dozen
papers written in the 70s and early 80s
explored what the human mind is doing
when it's making that kind of judgment
when it's making a judgment and
conditions of uncertainty when it's
valuing a stocker valuing a baseball
player or making a medical diagnosis or
voting for a political candidate what
and that that what his story is really
about are the systematic errors the mind
makes that this team the Oakland
Athletics is exploiting when I saw that
I went home no I'm because because I
knew that the people in that baseball
front office were seeking categories
they were thinking about the kinds of
mistakes that the market made they were
aware that a good-looking player was
going to be overvalued so when they saw
a player was good-looking they just kind
of they would tend not to pay much
attention to him they because if he was
any good at baseball he would be
properly valued they were also aware
that a hideous-looking player or a phat
player or a player with two club feet
there might be some value there they
were aware that players that looked like
players who had played and done well
would be overvalued players who looked
like nobody else would be undervalued
they were aware the players who did
things that were very very vivid power
power power hitters people who are fast
on the field things are all you know
stuck in the mind in the memory would be
over
people who had subtle skills that were
nevertheless extremely important like an
ability to determine whether a ball was
a pitch was a ball or a strike and I
promise I won't say any more about
baseball the that that would be
undervalue so they had this these ideas
of the systematic mistakes but they
never connected it up with these guys
work although they were familiar with
behavioral economics so that's so that's
the beginning now I can continue because
I can get you to Danny Kahneman you
mention because that dude so so here I
am sitting thing I screwed up my own
book that I missed a trick and it
bothered me it bothered me for the
better part of two or three years I
think about I think what I wouldn't read
their papers I thought that's
interesting that's which rista guy want
to write a book about it I mean the
academic paper is really written to
drive people away from them
yes date you know if he would say oh the
academics would say oh they're wonderful
writers would which one of the bad
writers look like and really really bad
yeah yeah but and it the reason is that
academics are running for a narrow
audience of people who are trying to
destroy them and so they lit they write
in this Crouch they're terrified they
they're terrified of making a mistake
and and so only after their hugely
successful and tenured and no one can do
anything bad to them they bought are
they brave enough to make a joke you
know and it's it's so anyway the papers
the ideas in the papers were really
interesting for academic papers they
were very well written but if it had
just been that Ida said well I missed a
trick but I was having drinks with a
friend I have a friend who serves as a
kind of literary therapist for me who
happens to be a psychologist at the
University of California Berkeley we
meet kind of once a month and just talk
about our problems and I said to him you
know it's been bothering me this thing
in your field these guys named Kahneman
and Tversky that do you do you know
anything about them and he laughed he
said
I was I was Amos Tversky teaching
assistant and and Danny Kahneman was
half a mile from your house and he said
I'll email him now go see him so I went
up to see Danny economy just to see what
it was I had missed and I get there and
he had won the Nobel Prize in Economics
in 2002 as a psychologist to knew not
much economics which is a pretty good
trick uh and he and I thought I never
met a Nobel Prize winner and I didn't
know what you were I didn't know how to
I felt like they would be some ceremony
and meeting this guy so when he opens
the door he's got shorts and bare feet
and his hair is sticking up every which
way he looks absolutely miserable and I
say something like oh what an honor to
meet you and he looks like I'm crazy and
he says you mean the Nobel Prize he says
that's so overrated he says don't pay
attention to that he says the big
problem is you come on a horrible day
it's he says I've thrown my book in the
garbage can they've made me write a book
they've talked these people these evil
agents and publishers talk me into
writing a book about my intellectual
life and it's it's so bad I realized
yesterday the day before was going to
ruin my reputation
and so I've thrown it away and I had
this conversation with him about his
book and it emerges in the course of
this conversation that he has been on a
basically a several-year quest while
he's been writing this book to persuade
himself that his book is awful and he's
done things like distribute $5,000 give
$5,000 to a friend of his in the field
and his his field psychology to
distribute to young smart people in the
field who will remain anonymous to him
to write hatchet jobs of his own book so
he will learn to hate his book and I was
why was low you know I thought got how
bad can this thing be and I took some of
it with me and it was it was thinking
fast and slow it was a book that has
sold seven million copies now it's a
book that a bit like the pickety book
I'm not sure everybody got to the end
however it's filled with interest
I mean filled stuff with interest so the
beginning of this really
it was me running back up to his house
saying don't throw that thing away
really and he said you know rightly you
don't know anything you know I you know
you're it's nice of you to say you don't
know anything but baguette was the
beginning of a relationship and we go on
these long walks in the Berkeley Hills
and that walks invariably turned back to
his relationship with Amos Tversky which
was more than an intellectual
collaboration it was a love affair it
was an absolute love affair without the
sex because I think for them sex was
just like second-rate compared to
thinking and and they they and it was
clearly tumultuous love affair and the
ideas that they had grew out of this
relationship and I started to think hmm
maybe there's a story that's a love
affair about these people and and the
ideas are part of the story but it's
about this relationship and the more I
was dug into it the more I saw that this
collaboration it was about collaboration
that the things they did together were
very unlike the things they had done
separately and I got interested in that
notion that but people do together gets
it can get very interesting if the
people in all the right people
collaborating so that was the beginning
I was the beginning of oh maybe this is
a book and so that's like late 2007 it
is till 2015 and I've between 2007 2015
I'd made five 10-day trips to Israel
I'd interviewed every old person who
knew them I wandered around Amos Amos
had died in 1996 I'd wander in Amos his
life I gotten access to his papers
oddly I'd found out that the one term
I'd taught at Cal Berkeley I had a
student named oranger ski he was very
fond of who was a mrs. oldest son and he
opened the doors to the family you know
memories and so I gathered string for
eight years before I decided I actually
had a book and for the longest time I
thought this isn't
a book from me so in it and would
finally drove me to write the thing I
mean the problems were obvious I didn't
know anything I might even have a story
to tell myself why I should be writing
us a book about two psychologists
because this isn't a book about
economics it's a book about psychology
that happens to end up having a big
effect on economics I am a happy boy
from New Orleans Louisiana my subjects
were at least one of my subjects was a
horribly neurotic unhappy Jew from
Israel and the backdrop to the work was
Israel in the birth of the Israeli state
and I thought I have no business with
that subject matter and then there was
this other problem where I've never
really felt I had a problem with my
subjects being smarter than me I always
felt like I was the B student writing
about other B students and or at least
if they were very smart like Wall Street
people they were in a B student
environment it wasn't really an
intellectual environment and and the
laughter is knowing isn't knowing
laughter but but this was this was the B
student writing about the a students
which is really tricky I knew that no
matter how good I got at them that I
would have a hard time getting my mind
fully around them and at some level I
knew that no matter how good a book I
wrote they would if Amos was alive and
Danny would would be dismissive of it so
so all this that served as kind of a
break and what saved me was the
characters getting to know these two
characters which I'm happy to talk about
the character the characters are
wonderful and actually Amos Tversky
partly maybe partly because he's only
living through the stories that you're
you're telling about him is very
obviously incredibly funny
no I didn't know but I wanted to know
him having read some of these quotes and
jokes he had he had this wonder because
it has it is as you say it's a very
unusual Miller for you but I think for
any of us who would read your books that
it's in the backdrop of war and the
beginning of Israel so you've got
someone who's going out being a
being in the army at the same time or
being Air Force at the same time as
having these thoughts on having this
academic life which is something which
is so jarring for people so I think that
was something completely different about
that character but he also just has all
these great lines and you'll you'll I'm
sure tell us many of them but I loved
him talking cross with his soldiers on
his detail who said didn't wear helmets
because they said if they were gonna get
killed there's a bullet with their name
on it and he would say well what about
all the bullets that just say to whom it
may concern' and his his organization of
his stuff the letters and things that
would just pile up on the desk where he
says the great thing about things that
are really urgent is if you wait long
enough they're not urgent anymore yes
and he had he had you would tell people
he was so regarded he was so one of the
very unusual is very unusual traits was
he was immune to social embarrassment he
thought people wasted way too much time
avoiding social embarrassment and he if
he found himself in any kind of
gathering that he had bored him or
didn't think it was worth his time small
dinner party staff meeting faculty
meeting board meeting
he'd up and leave he just up and leave
and he'd tell people he'd tell his
people who had asked him about it he'd
say you know it's funny when you're
sitting then you realize this isn't
worth your time and please don't take
this advice the the the it's very hard
to think of the excuse why you need to
be gone but if you get up and you just
start walking it's amazing how fast your
mind comes up with the reason and he
would tell you know his graduate
students would walk in on him and he was
you know he was by the time by the late
80s he's known as Famous Amos to them
because in his the little world he cares
about he's worshipped by people he's
thought to be by everyone I interviewed
who knew him the smartest man they ever
met and he did it without without
pretension
he did it he was he was just smart he
had a kind of logicians mind that that
caused people to think well Richard
Nisbett the psychologist at Michigan
said after he spent time with him he
designed what he said was the shortest
intelligence test ever design the
Tversky test he called it and it was the
longer it takes you after you meet Amos
Tversky to figure out you're stupider
than he is this stupider you are and and
nobody disagreed with that and Amos
didn't disagree with it either but it's
hard you know I want to tell you honest
a bit about him because you know the
stories there were many stories like
this in Israel there is a prize given to
a young young physicist called The Wolf
Prize and the wolf prize is a bit like
maybe the bait surprise in in in the
United States that in economics the
person who gets it often goes on to get
the Nobel Prize and Ames was passing
through Israel this is after he'd moved
to the United States and they're having
a party for The Wolf Prize winner at Tel
Aviv University and the hostess of the
party who was inviting mainly physicists
wanted Amos to come along and he comes
along and the next day she gets a call
from the winner of the Wolf Prize and
who says who was that physicist I was
talking to and he describes Amos
physically it takes her takes her a
while to figure out who he's talking
about and then she finds us oh no no no
that's that's not physicists that's Amos
Tversky he's a psychologist and The Wolf
Prize winner said that's not possible he
was the smartest physicist I've spoken
to and and how he did this is it's a
curious thing but he had them he had the
mind of a logician and he would he could
just take things you said when with very
little knowledge let you see them in a
different way
so
all of us to say is that he was kind of
he was he was a powerful character one
of the problems I had in writing him I
thought that I thought was I was gonna
have is that he was dead I couldn't
speak to him but he made such an
impression on everybody who met him he
his file cabinets filled with his papers
still sit outside his office
they've been there for 21 years in the
halls of Stanford University nobody
wants to get rid of him
he saved only what he wanted to save so
he speaks from the grave in a very clip
with a very clear signal he was you know
that the his graduate students were
described in me coming in to him once a
week he'd answer his mail or look at his
mail and it'd have them in neat piles
yeah Monday's mail Tuesday mails
Wednesday mail and he'd he would be on a
desk and they'd say it would be by the
late 80s it was piled up every day
because everybody wanted him for
something they wanted to give him an
honorary degree or come to his their
dinner party or ask him to consult them
and he would he'd look at the letters
and two out of three he just throw in
the garbage can and he told one of his
graduate students who was asking him you
know that's a personal letter to you and
you didn't even open it he'd say I have
a what can they do to me rule if they
can't do anything to me I just chuck it
away and and so this person who was so
particular about what he said how he
spent his time what he kept emerges is a
very clear character in a way oddly the
Danny Kahneman does not who was a very
murky changeable shape-shifting
character but the the the power of the
personalities and the oddness of the
combination nobody who knew them in
Israel could imagine how they could
collaborate nobody could see you know
how the relationship worked the the
thinking was Amos had no time for
difficult people I mean he thought life
was pretty simple and he thought people
were basically pretty simple and the
complexity they added to it was mostly
bullshit and and but every now and then
a complicated person enters his life and
his book cut his life and it's because
he's complicated in a really and
Steinway and Danny was complicated in a
really interesting way Danny brought you
know it was Danny brought a kind of
artistic imagination to the logicians
scalp and and and Amos Amos went to work
on it
any way he could think about but just
going back a little bit on the the
backdrop which is this unusual one in
terms of the early years in Israel and
they'd both had which we don't
necessarily need to go into here but
they'd both had their own kind of
harrowing family experiences and loss
and you do make the point in the book or
in that and I think even it's Danny
Kahneman makes the point that perhaps
it's because they had that experience
and they're surrounded by war in Israel
and the threat of war that they look at
some of these things differently when
actually economists are often have done
these elaborate that when they
experiment or they think about choosing
between things it's usually between two
games you know you're gonna make money
this way you're gonna make money that
way and that's often how finance is
thought about but if you're thinking in
terms of losses one of the insights of
behavioral economics is that you think
very differently about avoiding a loss
or suffering a loss so do you think that
did you know the backdrop in Israel did
affect the way they approach some of
these problems gave them a bit more of
an insight absolutely I think the so one
time Danny said to me interesting once
that when they were in a room alone
together just talking what they were
doing even though they in basically
invent the field of behavioral economics
and even though they've been a field
inside psychology called judgment
decision-making even though their work
kind of systematically touches lots of
parts of of life they're just thinking
how do what makes people tick they're
just having fun talking about things
they've seen and he said they were
talking usually what they're talking
about is war or Israeli politics things
they've seen in
armie the things they were observing in
the Israeli political life ah
and they'd made some conscious decision
and why I never quite understood not to
include any of those examples in their
work the start of the conversation is
what they're seeing in Israel but it's
even more than that I mean I think that
when you look at who they are as people
I mean Danny Kahneman I mean this is
this is a man who spent aged seven to
eleven as a Jew in France hiding from
Nazis because his father had misjudged
the Germans intentions his father who
had lived through World War one said
I've seen this all before and the
Germans are no threat to the Jews we'll
stay we won't go to Israel and and Danny
I mean some idea of how how simple and
clean however simple clear self-assured
confident Amos Tversky was Danny
Kahneman was the opposite and in you
know someone once said to me Danny
superpower is doubt that where everybody
else's mind comes to rest his refuses to
he has some great idea he makes it even
greater by doubting his own own great
idea he's never settled and where does
that come from I mean part of it kinda
comes from his experience it with war
with he watched he he and his family
spent four years living in chicken coops
and barns he watches his father die of
untreated diabetes he watches every day
as a child for four years he gets down
on his knees and says a prayer he says
dear God I know I'm but a speck in the
universe and you don't care about me but
could you please just let me live one
more day in this period of his life he
discovers or cultivates a really
peculiar imagination and this
agitation is central to their work but
none of its self-consciously by the way
all I'm telling I'm telling you about
Danny Kahneman came out on long walks
with him answering or saying it kind of
by the by not realizing how interesting
it was and this is just generally true
that the best characters don't know
their characters and he really doesn't
know what a great character is he thinks
he's normal so think about that and he
also thinks that his childhood has
nothing to do with who he is he told me
that he says I'll tell you all this
because you're asking the questions but
I don't think it's who it's because
anything do with Who I am but I think
imagine this he he discovers when he's
hiding in chicken coops and afraid he's
gonna be killed every day this very this
this imagination that takes him out of
where he is and he's the imagine himself
doing preposterous things like
single-handedly defeating the German
army and he says it feels like it had
happened it gave me that kind of feeling
like I had and he said so it was such a
peculiar ability or a tendency that when
he gets out of France and is in Israel
and is safe he finds he shouldn't
imagine having the things he wants to
get and wants to achieve
they shouldn't imagine being first in
his class because the the the experience
of imagine a imagining that is so vivid
it's as if he's got it and he loses his
motivation to go and get it so I mean
it's so extraordinary that he doesn't
allow himself I mean he because at the
end in 2002 when he's sitting there
waiting for the Nobel Prize call he
hasn't allowed himself to imagine what
it would be like to know wilfully stop
himself imagining what it would like be
like to win the Nobel Prize now I would
like to come back to that at some point
because that scene is just it's
breathtaking to me would he put himself
through but he but these experiences I
mean inform their work in all kinds of
ways and the and their war experiences I
mean Danny if we go back to you know my
book starts with Moneyball
and and the premise of Moneyball is
these experts using their gut are
inferior to a crude algorithm
I think the first example of Moneyball
that I've encountered is Danny Kahneman
age 21 in the Israeli army being asked
to to use his psychological training
which he's largely acquired by himself
because there's no there's no psychology
department at the Hebrew University to
use what he's learned in books to see if
he can improve the selection of Israeli
officers because he is they're having
problems with the officer corps the
performance on the field is poor and
Danny looks at how the Israeli army is
choosing officers in 1954 and they're
choosing them by basically Scouts people
who think they know what an officer is
interviewing a young man for a little
bit and saying he's officer material and
dave says that's not going to work as
well as an algorithm and he builds the
algorithm to to evaluate young men that
is used to this day by the Israeli army
funny aside Danny I took Danny we went
for a week to Israel and I wanted to go
see his military past and he and I went
to the base where they trained soldiers
and he got there and there was a huge
crowd of really pretty Israeli female
soldiers waiting for us and it and I
thought you know Danny was in his late
70s at that point I'm a man he's got it
going on and and eternal they'd put on
the manifest
the Danny Kahneman was coming with
Michael Lewis today and there is an
Israeli underwear model named Michael
Lewis who's got unbelievable abs and to
Danny's chagrin with a minute we walked
through the gate they look at it and
they all just fade away but but I mean
his he's noodling around as a 21 year
old in the Army in response to practical
demands made on him by the Israeli army
with
the whole notion of what's wrong with
intuitive judgment we should get on to
behavioral economics and what you think
is the crux of what they undid if it
wasn't undoing project this friendship
and in fact we were we were starting to
get on to it there but what do you think
of the sort of the greatest insights all
the things that have affected the world
when you talk about it changing there's
two ways to think about their work one
would be the way and intellectual would
look at their work and say the two
bodies there they did they made two big
contributions one was to this field of
judgment where they uncover cognitive
bias the idea of cognitive bias that the
idea that even when a the mind should be
essentially kept doing is calculating
statistics should be should be making a
statistical estimation that's not what
the mind does what the mind does is it
it tells a story and the story is warped
by by various kind of kinks in the mind
it's warped by the way memory works and
it's warped by the way the mind makes
similarity judgments by the way it
thinks in stereotypes and they did all
kinds of little experiments to show that
you could distort people's answers to
questions that had a right answer
even professional statisticians answers
to questions that a right answer in
predictable ways and this work has all
been replicated over and over and over
this doesn't have the work of
replication problems of that a lot of
Social Psychology is facing now so for
example I mean one of these they could
where they they caught they they end up
dreaming of lots of fancy
incomprehensible jargon for what they
discover they call the rules of thumb
that the mind is using when it's when
it's telling these stories trying to
judge what's going to happen in the
world or they call them heuristics and
they find several heuristics and they
put names to them so let's take one
anchoring the idea of anchoring is that
you can distort a person's judge
by throwing a totally irrelevant piece
of information right up front before
they have to make the judgment and this
is a good example of just how a kind of
weirdly ingenious their experiments were
and how you can hear you know Danny and
Amos would say that when they were in
the room they would but they would be
doing is laughing you can kind of hear
the laughter behind the experiment but
they they built a wheel of fortune and
the wheel of fortune has 99 numbers on
it one two ninety-nine and it and they
invite their lab rats students and
whoever off the street to come into a
room and spin the wheel of fortune and
the fortune and the wheel lands on a
number then they ask the lab rat a
question what percentage of the of the
countries in the united nations come
from africa and people who spun a high
number tended to estimate a higher
number of countries in the united
nations from Africa and people spun a
low number to spend the lower number
they did this over and over in all kinds
of way showing you could you could do
what Donald Trump does every day right
you can distort people's judgment by
throwing out stuff up front and you
could and you could predict how that
would be so this body of work they call
their work in judgment and intellectual
then say well then what they did is
moved on to decision-making which is a
more sterile study of Gamble's and if
it's here where they're trying to figure
out why people reverse preferences which
which are not supposed to do why I mean
to put it the way you Richard Thaler put
it to me so why when you walk into the
deli and you're they say we say what do
you have what kind of sandwiches you had
do you have and the guy behind the
counter says we have roast beef or
turkey and you say I'll have Turkey and
then he says oh no no we actually have
some ham in the back and you go hmm then
I'll have roast beef says what people do
that would people do a version of that
which is they're not supposed to do
right it kind of screws up a lot of
economic theory if if the
the choices people make change a lot if
you change the context in which they
make the choices so they do they do work
studying the way people respond to
Gamble's and when they're doing this
work they stumble upon some insights
that become a paper called prospect
theory which believe me you don't want
to read but it is that paper that live
wins them the Nobel Prize that Wednesday
in the Nobel Prize in Economics but the
the the the most interesting insight in
the paper is is that if a gamble is
framed as in a domain of gains if it's
if the person who is making the gamble
is thinking they're playing with gains
they're risk-averse that they're they're
less likely to take they won't take the
same bet that they would take if there's
think they're starting from a loss so
the this the people that people have a
different risk profile if they are think
of themselves as losing then if they
think of themselves as winning and this
has lots of implications but you know
you say we should be talking about
economics and you know it does say that
up there I did not dream up this title I
think so I'm a move-on that's academics
would say that's what they did and and
at the prospect theory paper what it
really did was make it you know
academically respectable for economics
to start talking about psychology and
about the insights of psychology whereas
psychology had never been able to work
its way into economics these people blew
a hole in the side of economics and
shove some psychology into it and
Richard Thaler comes along and reads
these papers and is inside of economics
and starts to deploy the psychological
insights in economics for which he's now
won a Nobel Prize I don't think of it
but I think that's a pretty reductive
way to think about their collaboration I
think that they were just these two
Israeli intellectuals who really almost
or accidental psychologists both of them
who were at odds with their own field
thought
much of their own field was nonsense who
really are just asking what's going on
inside the mind and trying to find
scientifically respectable ways to
investigate it and yeah they do generate
all this stuff that ends up being
internalized by economics and by
psychology and other fields but they
they also have all of this stuff that
just ends up on the cutting room floor
which interested me as much as the stuff
they whereas they were famous for they
spend an awful lot of time a year of
their lives
in investigating the role of regret and
decision making the anticipation of
regret they they dream up experiments
where they have a lottery and people
receive these lottery tickets and they
find that people who who have who
receive a number whose number is one
away from the winning lottery ticket
have more regret about the lottery the
people whose number is far away I mean
crazy stuff right that shouldn't happen
but and the and the book got this title
from some of their work that never found
its way into print which which is a
Danny Kahneman gotten it into his head
as only Danny Kahneman would that he
wanted to study the rules of the human
imagination now the idea that the
imagination has rules is itself an
imaginative leap and it comes to him
again again it goes right back to Israel
and war his nephew who would was a
navigator in a fighter pole in a fighter
Israeli fighter jet had been killed in a
trap in an accident
a day before he was due to get out of
the Air Force
he'd been in for five years or a day
short of five years and he'd been killed
because a flare had gone off and blinded
a pilot the piece pilot and apparently
when you're in a jet and you're flying
that fast you can't tell whether you're
ascending or descending and they thought
they were going up they were going down
and they flew right into the ground
so Danny goes to funeral and he loved
this kid but Danny because he's Danny
doesn't grieve instead what he does is
watch other people grieving and he sees
what they're doing is essentially trying
to imagine their way back out of the
tragedy a lot of what people are saying
or can be formulated as if only
statements if only he'd gotten out of
the Air Force a day earlier
if only that guy had not shot that flare
and Danny thinks well if you're gonna if
you're gonna engage in this in this game
called imagination creating alternative
realities there are a million different
ways you could undo it if only had been
born a girl
if only there hadn't been an Israeli Air
Force if only they'd move like they said
they were gonna move before he went into
the Israeli Air Force nobody went back
that far they started at the end of the
event and they undid the first thing
that it happened in time that you could
undo and change the outcome so he said
he starts to noodle on what are the
rules like what are the rules of these
statements they start to put people
through tests undo this tragedy how do
you undo this tragedy they describe a
tragedy undo it and they get to things
it's at that point actually that their
relationship comes undone because at
that point Danny is thinking that Amos
isn't paying sufficient attention to his
thoughts that Amos has become too famous
and is the whole relationship is premise
tana kind of uncritical acceptance by
Amos of Danny's ideas and he's not
responding in the way that Danny would
hope but Amos is actually taking Danny's
ideas and try to turn it into math
trying to turn it into logic trying to
frame them in a way that you could
publish in a paper and I said no I know
this because in Amos his file canvas was
a folder that was called the undoing
project and I when I showed it to Danny
he was ashen that Amos had spent so much
time thinking about it but but this sort
of work was as beguiling as the work
that actually has the effects it has
but if we and if we talked a little bit
about the broader impact and it isn't
just an economics because it's seeing
these insights about people's psychology
has informed policymakers and thinking
about health policy and all of these
things but and it's been around for a
while as as we know because 2002 was
when they won the Nobel and then more
recently now Richard Taylor's won it but
I wonder it's it started off and it's
often been known as a criticism of
economics and of science
misunderstanding or making assumptions
about human nature that were wrong but
then it seems to sort of end up sounding
like a criticism of humans for being
stupid because you're talking about
Richard Taylor talks about Homer
economicus he thinks the best model is
Homer Simpson for rather than sort of
Vulcan you know dr. Spock does that do
you think they actually were saying
people were stupid no because that often
does seem to be the subtext he talks
about even first pieces that were not
into in artificial intelligence would
occasionally say things Amos had if Amos
had some vices and one of his vices is
that he liked a cutting remark and he
was asked does your does your work have
any bearing on artificial intelligence
and he said I'm much less interested in
that than I am a natural stupidity and
that's and but but they didn't think
that way they thought in fact when it is
more thoughtful moments what Amos is
saying is human beings are too hard on
themselves because essentially so that
some of the big things that fall out of
their work are people don't decide
between things they decide between
descriptions of things and if you change
the description you change the decision
which is troubling to economists but
another thing that falls out of their
work is people are always trying to make
a probabilistic world deterministic
they're there they're taking things that
are inherently unpredictable
and pretending they can be predicted and
as there was a there was a throwaway
line on one of his folders I saw you
scribbled he said reality is not a point
it's a cloud of possibility and he they
would say that look this business of
after something happens people coming in
to explain why it happened as if it
should have been predicted is nonsense
they would have looked at the election
of Donald Trump this happened instantly
right Trump's elected and all of a
sudden they're pieces in the New York
Review of Books about how this we do
this as a result of these inevitable
forces in American life and trunk you
know we could you know the implicit is
you should have seen it coming and their
point is there's a lot you don't you
can't see coming but our mind does this
thing where we tell stories were that
dish reassure ourselves that we could
have seen it coming that we want to make
the world seem more predictable than it
actually is
and they were on this in a big way they
write what really wrote a paper called
on the psychology or prediction and they
showed the way but mainly what they were
after when they did that was they showed
how you could screw up how people would
predict but but so their point is not
that people are stupid their point is
that FAL ability is human and when you
take it into so they get they get I
think the reason that people when they
think of their work think of economics
is there's a Nobel Prize in Economics I
think that if there were in a Nobel
Prize in Economics and economics didn't
have the social status that it enjoys
that what people would be saying about
their work is oh my god look what
they've done in the field of medicine
you go in the middle of this book
there's a section with a guy who studied
with both of them who a doctor named
Donald Meyer who works in a what is
essentially Canada's largest trauma
center and his Canada's largest trauma
center because it's set up next to
Canada's largest freeway so the carnage
comes off the freeway and the doctors
have to make quick diagnose
these of these horrible cases often with
patients who can't communicate with him
and Don rental Meijer job is to sit
there and check the judgement of the
doctors with essentially a filtering him
through what he knows about condiment
diversity the kind of mistakes they
might make this looks like no you you
can't say that that's a collapsed lung
so quickly the reason you're saying it's
collapsed song is you just had two other
people who just came in with the
collapsed lungs there and he has saved
lives internalizing the their thinking
in powerful thing about that is it's the
the tests are themselves designed by the
doctors but then when you input when you
superimpose it on their actual
day-to-day behavior it's more efficient
than the doctors who create well that's
right they did so they did all kinds of
funny work with Amos you know he was he
was aware that one way to smuggle
psychological insights into real life
was through the economics discipline and
it was just because of the accident
economists were in government that
economists there was a Council of
Economic Advisers but there wasn't a
Council of psychological advisors and he
would have said there should be a
Council of psychological advisors but
but the Amos was was banging on
economics just because he knew that was
a way to get the ideas out into the
world but he was also banging on
medicine because he saw it as such a
high stakes thing and they did one of
their studies it's a he did with Don
reto meier the doctor with Stan Stanford
doctors to dramatize to physicians just
how susceptible their minds were to the
various illusions that call them into
risky dug out was they they gave them a
experiment where they went to ecologist
at Stanford and they said they gave them
this scenario you have a patient with
terminal cancer will be dead for sure
within seven years but there is an
experimental surgery you can perform the
problem is the patient might die on the
operating table but if they survive the
surgery
there
cured with one group of subjects they
told they told them that there is a 90%
chance the patient will survive the
surgery with the other group of subjects
doctors they said there's a 10% chance
they will die on the operating table
it's the same thing the patient the
doctors who were told there was a 90%
chance of survival were almost twice as
likely to want to perform the surgery
so you you you wonder not only how
doctors are making decisions but you
wonder if you wonder if doctors who want
to mate who want to make money from the
surgery or presenting to patients the
statistics in a certain way so they
accept the surgery you wanted this is
nudge in the medical world and it's
found its way into public policy and
other walks of life but the the they
were aware that they were aware the
stakes were high in medicine and they
were all over medicine I mean one one of
the criticisms of nudge or at least when
you sort of step back after over a
decade of their being
we had the nudge unit in 10 Downing
Street but Cass Sunstein also worked for
the Obama administration is it sort of
ironically given that they were talking
about the complexities of probabilities
and why things might happen it kind of
seemed to give politicians an easy way
out to say well you know the
libertarians who don't want to force
people to do things and others who
really do want to kind of impose
regulations on things they can come
together with this nice nudge to the
libertarian paternalism right you don't
have to you don't have to force them but
you can have you can have these
miraculous results and in some areas
it's really worked and maybe in medicine
you've had some really transforming
results but I can't thinking you've also
kind of let people off the hook maybe
they should have be regulated you really
want to stop people doing something
maybe we'll stop using so much gas for
example petrol should you just be taxing
it more and not saying no I'm gonna
nudge them in this way or that way
sort of maybe what exaggerated how much
it's changed the world in for the
well it's just I think we've exaggerated
the complexity it's really simple there
been some simple manipulations that have
had a huge effects and that's that the
big one is savings that the big
contribution Richard Thaler has made in
in real life with his partner Cass
Sunstein is to incorporate and
government savings plans to change them
from opt opt in to opt out that the mere
act of asking someone to tick a box that
says no I won't I don't want to save 10%
of my earnings as opposed to ticking a
box that says yes I do
causes them to save you know double yeah
well they can't go home after the
effects have been huge they there are
other places in government where they
were at work looking for ways to do I
mean they've school nutrition in America
has been affected by them they've
changed the way the nutritional options
are presented they've changed the way
through the Agriculture Department the
way foods presented kids in the
cafeteria just by moving the vegetables
and the fruit to the front of the line
as opposed to back on the line
it's so there are lots of little things
like that all these they're not reached
not really economics right it's
psychology
so it's can one you're right it's
perhaps if you if anybody's overstating
I don't know who's overstating the
importance of all this stuff but but
it's it's it's a thing that's useful but
not everything it does change the
subject to something everybody can more
or less agree upon and it does get
people off the hook I agree with that
and there may be kind of limits to how
far it'll it is I think we should give
people a chance to ask some questions
there's lots of other things we can talk
about but if you put your hand up and
then wait for the for the microphone
I remember for this place it's very hard
to see all right here I'll take a few we
got numbers that's right you'll get a
number right over there okay so take
number one first Michael your books have
been very influential and that's given
you a certain power
do you feel you might choose a future
book to try and do something more useful
for society be targeted on attacking
corporate tax avoidance or some other
social good rather than the more
intellectual things you've done no so
it's it's funny you say this because I
think the minute I try to be worthy I
cease to be useful
yes having lived through an document at
each boom-and-bust since 87
and I worked with behavior economics do
you think the cycles are inevitable you
know it's not because of behavioral
economics that I think the cycles are
inevitable and behavioral economics has
a bit to say about this but not all that
much it's just the cycles seem
inevitable because they've all it's been
ever thus so do I think people will will
altogether do stupid things and we'll
all pay prices for them in the financial
markets over and over and over again yes
which I think sort of made people forget
you could have a real financial crisis
that really affected the real economy
was that you had that crash and you
didn't have a recession and people paid
the price in the markets but there
wasn't a broader effect we didn't go
through I think I would also difference
in those the crisis were all the same
and you can even make a case that the
at7 crisis stock market crash was a
crash was sort of robot induced because
it was portfolio issues people are
following rule it was rule based
investing that drove the market down it
was it was it was different from very
different in flavor from the 2007 to
know if you've used any other principles
of behavioral economics or psychology
the marketing of your books something
some photos on the cover the color the
caption the titles if there's a be
testing of oh this will inspire
purchases so using them for commercial
means well penguin is here my publisher
we could ask them I tell you more
generally is that the the these it's
very hard when you're exposed to these
guys for as long as I was exposed to
them not to have them start to infect
your life I didn't really think of it as
I didn't really think much about how
they could help me sell my books but I
don't think that much about how to sell
the books so that's it that's part of
the problem the publisher does it I
don't do it I do what they tell me to do
and and I would and it's still that old
process of how a book sells is still a
little mysterious to me but there were
other effects that I've really
internalized and kind of give one it's
so this is an another example of how how
so much of what they did is not
contained by a vessel called medicine or
economics or judgment or decision making
so Kahneman was they each Danny and Amos
both had lots of different roles in the
Israeli military and one of Kahneman's
roles was to Train Air Force fighter
pilot instructors not the pilots he knew
nothing about flying he was teaching
people how to teach and in the course of
training these instructors he got this
feedback from them saying basically that
when you're when you're teaching fighter
pilots how to fly
criticism works in praise does not and
he said you know what why do you think
that and the instructor said well when
we criticize them he says when when a
pilot has done something spectacular and
we've praised them we've noticed that
the next thing he does is less
spectacular and we does something really
bad and we get on him we noticed he
improves and we've taken away from this
that that they're kind of you know they
get fooled themselves if you praise them
but they responded to the toughness to
the
they respond to pain not pleasure and
Kannada said well that's not what's
going on that's a statistical illusion
that's reversion to the mean anytime you
do something especially spectacular the
next thing you're gonna do is a little
less spectacular and anytime you do
something is especially awful all left
to your own devices you're the next
thing you're gonna do is going to be a
little bit better and so this isn't
about your words this is about it this
is a statistical phenomena but being
Kahneman he doesn't just stop there he
says the world is telling everybody who
teaches people that parents teachers
coaches that that the pain works and the
pleasure doesn't because because of this
feedback this illusion that the
criticism leads to improvement after a
bad thing happens and the praise leads
to it and it leads to less lesser
performance so in my idea when I when I
heard him describe this to me by the way
this was in his manuscript that he'd
chucked out into the into the garbage
can I said I thought you know in my own
we're subjected to this constant
enforcement of this message and so when
I parent or coach now I now take the
view that the criticism should be very
sparing and the praise should be
effusive for no other reason then quite
possibly my words are gonna have no
effect at all and if I'm going to
inflict either pleasure or pain I might
as well just inflict the pleasure but
but the but there are little things like
that or the undoing project yeah I watch
sports and and I have favorite teams and
and I get upset when they lose and I
spin a narrative in my head after they
lose about why they lost and and I
noticed that I blame the guy who screwed
up at the end of the game
that's you know god help the field goal
kicker who missed the extra point yes if
God helped
the kicker who missed the penalty kick
when in fact if you go back over the
game there's quite likely something to
have in the beginning of game that no
one got credit or proper credit or
proper blamed for that you could most
like more a lot more plausibly blame the
defeat on so I think when I when I watch
sports I think differently about how I'm
assigning credit and blame for whatever
just happened I mean anybody who watches
sports what an interesting exercise to
sort of see to get Danny and a missus
point about how the people want the
world to seem more deterministic than it
is is listen to the announcers as the
game shifts they they start they're
always telling a story that would in
that sort of suggests they have
explained why what just happened is
happening so if your team is winning
they have a narrative going about why
this team is so good how well coached it
is oh it's amazing what teammates they
are it's amazing the chemistry on this
team then all of a sudden they're losing
oh shit
the narrative changes oh oh it did you
hear there are drugs in the locker room
did you hear they have a it changes
instantly we do this in life
it isn't just we do this in life
constantly so they've they heighten your
awareness as you move through the world
without without being entirely useful
you know like without the game but you
one of the maddening things about their
work is they themselves would say what
they're saying their message like their
deep message is this isn't like this
isn't window dressing on our minds this
is who we are and we can't change who we
are that you're gonna make these
mistakes even if you know about them as
easily as you make as you cease to you
as even after an optical illusion is
pointed out to you you still see the
optical illusion that your mind will
still deceive you even if you know about
this and there's a limited use value
they are not a how-to book and they that
wasn't what they were really on about
but still as you move through the world
and you know their work it enriches your
life
yeah thank you was it easier was it
easier to write about Amos acutely
because he was gone or harder to write
about Danny because he was still present
was I worried that Danny was gonna be
mad at me and yes I was and and I
couldn't do anything about it the the so
although I had a mrs. Widow on my
shoulder so there was that that was a
little but they were at the end of their
relationship they were like two lovers
who had a horrible falling-out
and if you ever had friends who've
gotten divorced and you love them both
and you sit down there with them
independently it's amazing how they can
get you to hate Egypt the other one
you're right that's amazing how that you
the two story and the two stories just
don't sync up all the short story was
Danny was emotionally needy and neurotic
and Amos didn't see so it was
undignified to service those qualities
that and there's a line in a letter in
there these love letters the break these
break up letters and there's a line in a
letter from Amos to Danny that I think
this captures the spirit of the problem
in the relationship he says at one point
the line is I don't get your sensitivity
metric now anybody who can write that
will never get anybody's sensitivity
metric right and that they're so I
because I was writing in the end about a
dispute to which there were two sides I
was aware that both sides could the
potential be pissed off at me by how I
described it and I thought in my mind
what I should be doing is writing this
thing in such a way that the kind of
people who could write the phrase I
don't get your sensitivity metric would
take a mess a side of things and the
kind of people who would wonder how
could anybody write such a thing would
take Danny side of things and the result
is I didn't please anybody so I had
everybody a little upset with me in the
beginning but I don't think it it I felt
an obligation
Amos because he was dead to be
especially fair to come to do my best to
see his point of view because he wasn't
there to express it and Danny was and I
assume that Danny was yanking me all
over the place in my mind to see this
thing in a certain way good evening so
very much enjoyed the book one of the
impressions I got was that you could
enjoy it if you saw it as a sort of
academic tribute act to PT Barnum many
of the ideas held there I felt a lot of
the ideas of mr. conovan and mr. burski
right we're already held within PT
Barnum oh it's like a showman event well
that's funny analysis this is my own
personal impression well Amos did say at
one point to his son nothing we've done
isn't known to do really good used car
salesmen and there is some truth to that
that they that that's what they did is
is articulate what's going on when
people are being manipulated
not so much discovering that they're
being manipulated in the first place so
I'd agree with that there's some truth
to that could you stand up when you ask
the question so we can catch you yes I
was interested what you're saying about
the predictability of events obviously
in the big short you focus on people who
manage to predict for crisis of 2007 and
2008 and when I'm reading it I think
these guys are just a bunch of oddballs
you know they're not that people I would
naturally think are going to be
perceptive about future events do you
have an insight how to sort out the
oddballs from the naturally present
naturally perceptive so that's it's a
really interesting question because
you've discovered the weakness and the
big short the and the weakness is that
which I just hope people wouldn't know
but I'll tell you what it is because
it's because now it's you forced my hand
those people who got it right I knew I
could seduce the reader into following
them because they got it right because
nobody wants to be with a stupid person
people want to be with a smart person
and they did in fact diagnose what had
happened very well and could teach the
reader would it gone on inside the
financial system but the idea that they
were geniuses because they made all this
money there's some truth to it but that
isn't the greater truth is there was a
huge amount of luck in that but they
could easily have been right about what
was going on the financial system and
wrong on their bets and they got lucky
they got they all got lucky with the
timing
I used the readers willingness to
suspend disbelief in the presence of
people who had made huge sums of money
betting against Wall Street banks to
teach the reader about what had happened
I don't think that those people who were
this at the center of the Big Short have
any crystal ball they aren't that
they've subsequently proved themselves
unable to predict anything else
I mean they've all none of them have
that none of them have had a second acts
right I love them all they're all really
smart they were all really you know kind
of principled in seeing what was going
on and they were all really brave to
make the bets they did but they were
also all really lucky that's a really
that's a great question because the
psychologists are furious is called by
behavioral economics they feel like
their work has been stolen by economists
great stuff have been stolen and and
just relabeled economics and the
economists are getting credit for it
again so so I suppose
Thaler himself would say you can't so
how can i I mean I could try but but the
point of behavioral economics is to let
psychology and economics which I think
even Taylor Taylor said himself quoted
others saying that it should be
redundant to say behavioral economics
because that's what economics should
have been about in the first place about
the behavior of people but it shows how
stupid economists were that it took they
needed an extra adjective to add to it
I'm not sure that you're Michael you
talked about the fact they understood
human fallibility and I wonder whether
out of that there was a suspicion that
they actually thought the art of
economics and the attendant predictions
was worthless Amos had great respect for
economists he liked the rigor of
economics he liked the math of economics
and it was really Danny who dragged him
to the idea a systematic error he
wouldn't have gotten there without Danny
so they didn't think economists were
stupid and in fact the reverse Amos
thought the best of the economists can
arrow for example with whom he Thomas
Schelling with whom he was friends he
much preferred their company to the
company of his fellow psychologists but
he did think there were problems with
their field which is different and he
put this very nicely to an economist he
didn't particularly like but who a
prominent Harvard economist amos was
with him in the conference and they were
out having a drink or dinner and the guy
was going on and on about how his
students were all stupid and these
people in the markets he was watching
we're all stupid and and Amos turned
Rubin said you think everyone's stupid
but all your models assume they're smart
and rational how do you figure that one
out and and so he was aware there was a
problem in the field which he
distinguished from a problem with the
economists
okay the upside-down three thank you
very much that all you spoken a lot
about human fallibility and how being
fallible makes you stupid and how being
smart is being rational I just be
interested to know if you think there
are scenarios in which actually being
fallible producers say the second best
outcome falling short of always being
perfectly rational well I don't think
I've said that being that being smart is
being rational that I'm very sympathetic
to these these errors and the people who
make them less sympathetic to to people
who that to people who don't acknowledge
valid their fat develop their FAL
ability so I'm not sure I completely
understand the question I think it was
when we were talking earlier about did
they really think people were stupid but
I think it's that sense people feel
uneasy that this is that it's all about
how humans are stupid when you could say
the model of rationality is stupid
because it never bore any relation to
the way people think and and and there
is this great question what are we gonna
do about it and so the the model of the
doctor who's sitting there checking the
thinking of other doctors was what they
had in mind with what we was when you
asked them what we might do about it
it's funny these guys they briefly
thought they quickly decided after
trying to consult with Israeli military
leaders and government leaders and other
and that they realized that you were
never going you're never gonna change
the minds of grown-ups
you're never gonna teach them how to
think statistically as opposed to
intuitively when you should think
statistically they they then designed a
curriculum for Israeli schoolchildren
because they thought maybe if you get to
them when they're 10 and then they
abandon that they decided that's not
gonna work and where they ended up
unlike what you do with this
this fact that we are fallible we're
wired for certain kinds of FAL ability
was I think encapsulated in a little
there's a little moment in the book
where Amos is basically everybody by the
early eighties anybody who had a problem
with decision-making or judgment came to
Amos Tversky he was famous in the field
and more famous than day a lot more
famous than Danny and there was a a man
who ran the pilot training program for
Delta Airlines the big US airline and
there was a period in the late 70s and
early 80's where oddly Delta Airlines
was having problems with the judgments
of his pilots they there were several
weird things that happen judgemental
errors that caught that alarm the
management of Delta Airlines I mean what
the most curious one pilots were landing
in the wrong airports what do you think
how does that happen right I mean really
how does it happen and I talked to this
man who had called who ran the training
program who had called up Amos and said
what do we do what's going on and here
Amos winnin gave him a brief short
course on condiment averse key and and
then asked the guy and said to them
you're not going to the pilot who lands
in the wrong Airport there are people
gonna make mistakes but what is your
what does the cockpit look like I mean
what do people do in the copy he says
and the guy explained that at the time
the pilot was a autocrat that he would
the copilot's were not encouraged the
junior pilots encouraged to question the
captain and Amy said that's the best you
can do is change that change the culture
of decision-making so that the person
who is making the decision has other
voices in his ear because you why you
can't see your own mistakes while you
can't see you've been fooled by this
optical illusion sometimes other people
can and this guy who who was in charge
of 28,000 Delta Airlines pilot said Amos
Tversky in that one session changed the
structure the culture of the American
commercial airline cockpit we changed it
Delta than everybody else
because we saw the ways to move that and
that's kind of like like so so you you
never get away from the fal ability but
you you you know the best you can do is
sort of try to adjust your environment
for it you know dude this is Obama Obama
saw himself as a saw the job of
president is essentially a
decision-making job and he he he's tried
to structure his environment to prevent
him making the kinds of mistakes the
condiment reverse key would predict he
would make Trump is not number four at
the back what are the numbers so then I
can see um I just wondered if they had
any interaction with Dan Ariely the
other Israeli behavioural economists or
um what they thought of him or what you
think of him if he's as brilliant so I
saw I don't know Daniel I don't have
anything to say I think that they did
Danny Kahneman I really have written a
couple of papers together there are a
whole wave of young are now middle aged
Israeli academics who are their
disciples but I don't think Ariela is
one of them so you mentioned earlier
that there's a hospital that employs
someone to check doctors biases but then
you also mentioned that the biggest bias
of all is that we can identifies other's
biases but not our own so no matter how
much we learn we can't correct our
biases so are we condemned this
perpetual cycle where we need someone to
check our own biases and does that
inherently make the person who checks
the doctors bias as useful to be need
someone to check his biases yes actually
question one more question so I think ok
I think in the beginning no ok
just checking you talked about how the
the collaboration con went sour the end
and obviously history's littered with
lots of collaborations which last a very
long time and kind of ran their natural
course
were there any sense from the work you
did that there was rivalry and jealousy
between them that was actually at the
core so what caused the collaboration to
collapse you talked about that I just
wonder with her behind that there's
actually kind of some rivalry jealousy
that actually triggers it it was
interesting because I had I only had one
side alive to tell me but there was a
myslef to zone versions in his in his
files but the the which seemed to have
driven the collaboration I think which
drives a lot of collaborations is the
uncritical acceptance of each other's
ideas and as Danny said once he said
when we said something the other said
didn't ask is that true they asked what
might it be true of it was the
relationship was an improv comedy
relationship the structure of it that
you were if I say something to you you
don't reject it you accept it you build
on it however idiotic it may seem at
first and they did this with each other
and it just went places what happens is
because Amos gets very very famous he
gets a MacArthur Genius a reward without
Danny he gets there first the quickest
appointment 10-year two point minutes
Stanford in the history of the
university he's when Danny can't get a
job at a university there was an very
unequal division of spoils that caused
some jealousy but it wasn't the jealousy
that was the problem and I believe Danny
on this subject the problem was Danny
began to sense that Amos thought his
that he was he started to believe the
feedback he was getting from the world
and became any sense more criticism from
Amos as a result so instead of accepting
whatever Danny said and building on it
Danny felt like a bit of rejection so
this gets us to the Nobel Prize because
when Amos Tversky dies in 1996 there are
a lot of people who have told you that
he would have gotten the Nobel Prize in
Economics
alone but they don't give the Nobel
Prize in Economics to people who aren't
alive and now that he's not around when
people look at the work the person who's
alive is Danny so Danny having been
neglected for quite a long time during
the relationship everybody sees the
genius and Amos they can't understand
Danny's genius is harder to see in 2001
he's invited by Stockholm to come and
give a talk which he is an audition for
the Nobel Prize they know the work is so
important it deserves it they don't they
kind of ever heard rumors that Danny
wasn't as important as Amos because
that's been in the air for the entire
relationship he goes and gives a talk
and comes back and this is where I want
I wanted to get to this story because I
found it was so him and also spoke so
much to the relationship and what made
it tick and why it didn't tick when it
stopped ticking
Danny was given to believe this was in
2000 he was gonna if he was gonna get
the prize at all he was gonna get it in
2002 and at any given moment when the
economics prize is about to be given out
you're not gonna believe this there 100
people sitting by phones thinking
they're gonna get the Nobel Prize in
Economics or might so they're up at 4 in
the morning in the United States waiting
for the call from Stockholm and his amos
said there shouldn't be any of these
prizes for every one person who gets it
99 people are made miserable but Danny
was sitting by the phone with his wife
and the call doesn't come and as I said
he hadn't allowed himself to imagine up
to that point what it would be like to
get the Nobel Prize
so the caller's that come his wife says
kind of sadly Holwell and leaves the
room and he then allows himself to
imagine how it would go if he won the
Nobel Prize and what he imagines is
doing all the things for Amos that Amos
who didn't get his sensitivity metric
wouldn't do for him
he would bring a mrs. wife widow and
children to the ceremony he would write
a biography of Amos and weave it into
his acceptance speech he would he would
take a big
autograph famous and put it up over his
head as as he spoke and it received the
Nobel Prize he was gonna physically
insist on Amos getting joint credit for
the work in a way that Amos never
insisted the Danny gets joint credit for
the work it's what
ate at him and then the phone rings and
he gets the prize and he does all of it
well it's exactly 8:30 which is when we
promised people we can leave I mean one
of the interesting great lines in the
book which I was thinking of when you
were talking about the pilots is I think
and I you would remind me which one says
it this is it can be much easier to
change the world than to prove you've
changed the world and I think that is
true and we've had a sense of it from
you that is true of so many of their
ideas even there you can't always put
your finger on it and there may not be
easy policy solutions but they do come
to life in this book and it is on sale
in the foyer thank you very much thank
you
[Applause]